can I help you  y-yes yes you can I'm here to report a  terrible crime and what terrible crime  is that this one nah [ __ ] I told this  all wrong  quick history lesson this all started  when the Joker and I broke up  it was completely usual and soon enough  I was back on my feet ready to embrace  the fierce goddess within it's oh so now  that I cut ties with mr. J I'm about to  learn that a lot of people want me dead  uh alone and at the top of that list is  this guy  I wasn't the only daemon got them  looking for emancipation rob him you've  betrayed him  you killed his BFF what you are so cool  you're dumb enough to be building a case  against him so unless we all wanna side  very unpleasant death we're gonna have  to work together  sure  psychologically speaking vengeance  rarely brings the catharsis we hope for  yeah are we ready  oh [ __ ] is that a hyena in a bottle  named and bruised after that hunky wine  guy  you